he's the world's most famous performance
coach he's advised everyone from Bill
Clinton to Serena Williams from Leonardo
DiCaprio to Oprah his live arena event
sellout months in advance mentor me Tony
I don't wanna come threat of anybody
that work with the successful financial
athletes people in politics it's hunger
you know you and I both know
intelligence is brick dam valuable tool
but there are a lot of very smart people
or can't fight their way out of a paper
bag and then when you find somebody has
that Hunger the hunger that doesn't go
away that hunger to be more to do more
to give more that hunger that never ends
you know that's how you get these people
that are the best in the world at
whatever they do and so if you can I
think everybody has that hunger but for
some people it's been asleep for a long
time because they're afraid they're
afraid that I'm gonna get hungry I'm
gonna try I'm gonna fail and so it's
human nature to protect yourself from
the fear by just lowering your
expectations but one things I've learned
is you get what you tolerate you get
what you tolerate yourself you get rid
you tolerate in your life and sooner or
later we sometimes hit a point we say
not another day another hour this is
done I'm not walking this way I'm not
talking this way I'm not living this way
I'm not gonna be in this relationship
anymore I'm gonna change it and when
people do that that's the beginning of a
breakthrough the failure is part of life
I mean the difference for me though is I
like a failure as a stepping stone to
success it's a speed bump I know I'm
gonna fail but it's not failure if you
learn something and so gosh I've made so
many mistakes I've screwed so many
things up but every time I do it just
becomes it becomes a way for me to
explain to someone else what it takes
you know it's like here's what I've done
I think I have the ability influence
people because I talk about my failures
I talk about all the things that messed
me up but I show people that didn't let
it stop me and you only to stop you and
I think I think that's really the secret
matter and if everything you touch was
successful
first of all you got to relate to people
as much and also its be total bull and
everyone know it's both and also you'd
be bored silly I mean think about it if
you just said I want this to happen I
want this to happen you know people
don't value it they don't fight for you
know it's like you see kids sometimes in
it you know your parents will say you're
not gonna value this if you don't work
for it and your kid going oh well you
just give it to me
but it's true you know about things
we've worked the hardest for we value
the most so I think you know the purpose
of the goal is not getting it anyway the
purpose of goal you know is what who you
become
well you becomes gonna make you happier
it's gonna make you sad so I'm not
looking for an effortless approach
there's no such thing
so Tony one of the critics actually that
I once met said yeah Tony's techniques
they were great for about a year and a
half and then they wore off what do you
say to that
it's real simple if you don't work out
you don't get up you don't get a muscle
right so I always tell people this is
there's a daily practice like priming if
you don't do that if you get up and you
just have no discipline whatsoever you
get no value of anything your diets
don't work when you don't do them
exercise doesn't work when you don't do
them but most people have some
experiences that they want to shift and
once you shift those things your whole
life changes but life is constant growth
my life isn't here because I went to one
seminar one time and now my life is fit
for life I I workout I train my mind and
train my body it becomes a lifestyle
it's not just like you're depending upon
somebody else oh I'm not here to become
somebody's guru I'm not here to give
them a gift I'm here them to open up
their own gifts and that's really what
my work has been well I think the best
performers are focused on outcomes and
not activities if you try to manage your
to-do list and the world we live in
today where most of us have multiple
roles we're trying to be a great
business person a great husband a wife
great father great community member
whatever there's just so many roles you
can never get all your to do is done and
what helped me in my life was I started
one point saying I'm not gonna let
myself fail every day I'm not gonna
forget to-do list and I'm not gonna not
write a list and stuff that I don't fail
I need to focus on what matters most
I needed discuss organize my life in two
categories or I say these are the most
important outcomes and then I know why
I'm gonna do it if you know what you
really want the target and you know why
you have the focus and you have the fuel
then how to get there there's so many
ways to get there where would you start
from if you should start today in 2013
to launch a successful business well I
think any business dozen that if you're
coming from the moon or you've been here
forever and not being here at all you
have to find no you can't just come up
with an innovation people say well
innovations the key I know that all
businesses you know Deming talked about
this so many different teachers talked
about it's all marketing and innovation
drunk Drucker saying all businesses is
marketing innovation well what is that
innovation is finding a better way to
meet people's needs than anybody else
does and it's not enough just to
innovate you keep innovating Apple is a
perfect example yes you know it's the
most successful company in the world but
the leader was such an innovator he
drove an innovation culture that right
now there are a little bit of a lull now
most of us are hoping that they're gonna
turn that corner yeah but they're
they're still doing great products but
they're not real breakthroughs they're
not they're giving us some of the same
stuff but they are making it unique
enough and then the second part of the
business is marketing which is getting
people to want to do business with you
yeah well today we live in a world where
it used to be that you could put out the
average person would watch
advertisements and after four ads on
average at least in America what it is
in Europe if they were gonna buy they
would take some initial buying action
now takes 16 exposures so the cost is
not crazy
so how do you break through that the
only way to break through that is some
people do it by spending so much money
and creating crazy ads that make you pay
attention because they're sort of funny
or bizarre or raw but a lot of those ads
you don't buy their product you laughs
yeah you know the company but you don't
buy their product right cuz it's not
necessarily bringing you in the other
way a small business can do it is you've
got to figure an innovation that meets a
need that's missing right it's not
enough just to have innovation a lot of
business owners go oh I have this great
idea I'm so excited they're gonna launch
it but there's not that big a need if
you're gonna build a business of scale
has to feel a significant need in an
innovative way and then you got to
market it now how do you market it well
the best marketing of all is having a
product right that meets people's needs
so well that the word of mouth is off
the charts and then the second way to do
because that word if there's no
replacement for that word of mouth and
then a second
hey buzz let's let's make my career go
for 36 years right people say oh my god
not it was good not only had a good time
it was one of the greatest experiences
of my life it was there's nothing like
it you gotta go people think they're
crazy till they go get our experience
but then on the other side of it you can
also market today and have a huge
advantage if you make your mentality of
marketing what I call van V am
value-added marketing or instead of
trying to compete
eyeballs you go find out who that client
is and you find a way to meet their
needs and you do things for them that
really meet their needs I don't care if
it's educate them provide them an
insight something that gives them more
convenience the actual marketing itself
does that for people and then they begin
to understand you recognize you like you
trust you and wanted to business with
you and that's the way to do it today
because for example I was at Nike and
they called me up and they said you know
we want to do a TV ad for us and I said
look it's my first response was I didn't
do commercials cuz I did silly
infomercials for years because it was
the only way to reach people but I don't
do commercials and they came back and
they said but but your friends are gonna
do it I said really think we have
Richard Branson and Serena Williams and
Kanye West Kobe Bryant call me Bryan and
I'm like and they said it's gonna be
about it's gonna be you they'll be the
center of it again we're gonna pretend
Kobe is you and to give me this whole
thing so I called Richard and I said are
you really going he goes yeah I'm going
and Serena I'm really gone so we go to
do this piece you imagine how much money
they spent to get all those people in
one room to do this tongue-in-cheek ad
that really doesn't change it's nothing
about the product whatsoever it's just
to try to get your eyeballs and
attention so most small businesses don't
have those resources they have to make
up with it with an extraordinary product
that meets the needs and they got a
makeup order by finding a way to do
value added marketing so that people say
this is someone I want to do business
with you can blow out a Nike if you can
create a direct relationship with a
consumer and you can do that today
because of social media and because of
the impact of social media when you
serve people well I usually do
resolutions not work because they have
nothing to do with really resolving
anything they have more to do with
deciding something you'd like that
happen when we resolve Soraa wish it's
more wish it's a hope that's what I
think I should do and that's often a
reaction to what we don't like and when
you really resolve something
the shift in that is real because you
hear there's an identity shift it's
kinda like what people say to me why I'm
not supposed to cigarette for ten days
and I'll say why accountant so you can
tell people many days you'll ask me to
go back because when you're a person
who's made a shift in your identity
you're not a smoker anymore it's just
it's not a fight anymore like trying to
smoke or not smoke you just say I'm not
a smoker somebody off your cigarette you
wouldn't say what brand is it you'd say
no that's not
so making that shift in identity is what
makes a permanent change resolving
something requires that you cut off any
possibility going backwards it's burning
the boat so you take the island and most
people don't do that we're gonna become
emotionally fit because we have to
necessity is there but the thing look at
people hope is not positive thinking its
role model Sir John Templeton was one of
my heroes I interviewed him but not long
ago and he just passed away as you
probably know about a week ago here's
the man to start with nothing in 1939
you know Hitler is invading and he went
out at that time and said yeah maximum
pessimism is when you can do the best
this is when you can grow he went out
and he took stalks here in the US that
were on this floor and got him for a
dollar each borrowed $10,000 and built
the basis of a multi-billion dollar
empire today even though he's passed he
has this foundation that's right we had
a billion half dollar and down then it
gives away seventy million dollars a
year and it's all because this man when
Japan after the war with the foot that's
where he went when Brazil and which
South America's inflation was going
crazy that's where he went but no one
went to China that's where he went if
you go to a maximum pessimism is you can
shift it but with your kids they're
going to have to change they don't have
a choice and that's what's gonna make us
stronger and necessity is gonna make it
happen we can step up though by modeling
and one last thing quickly I think air
to get outside yourself when things are
the worst for you there's always
somebody doing worse two thirds are
almost a little more than half this
planet was of $2 a day we're stronger
than we think we are and we can train
ourselves to be able to take advantage
of the tough to test for us
the breakthrough happens by conditioning
your mind every day by feeding it a role
model or story it's putting yourself in
a peak state and you follow through by
getting physically strong it's creating
a little ritual of doing a little bit
each day and then you get momentum but
the most important thing of all let me
start out with why absolutely why is it
a must for you it doesn't have to be
here against the wall but it has to be
something you're hungry for because the
only difference in people is hunger and
if you're not hungry get around people
that are hungry and something will hit
you as a man I knew is capable more so
people can change their standard by
getting around where it's better people
can change their standard by getting
associated what's true like the bills
they gotta solve the problems they got
to do it or they can do it because
they're excited cuz there's something
new they want to take on everyone's
different but they gotta find the why
and they got to come up with some daily
rituals to get them going and just do a
step at a time
that's where you get momentum to stop
making the worst train of your life let
me do it that trade is trading time for
money mm-hmm most people don't think of
yourself as a financial trader but they
are there trading time for money you
want to trade instead money for money
you want money to become your slave you
want money while you sleep to go to work
for you and no matter how hard you work
no matter how much you work it's still
you until you make money your slave and
so this process step one you stop being
consumer you become an investor by
deciding a specific number you're gonna
set aside and you automate it I'll show
you how to do that is the first step you
want to talk about a failure I can
remember being on stage in the
Continental Center in New York City and
I had 18,000 people which in those days
would be a dream to have that many
people and you know I don't want to come
like a rock concert you don't sit for
three hour movie I'm gonna love you for
12 hours I got to deliver
you can vote with your feet in any
moment so it's been a killer day and
people are out of their minds and people
are so generous they come up hug you and
love you and and that seemed to you my
company went public I made 40 million
dollars you know on paper that day so it
should have been like the greatest
victory emotionally physically
financially contribution and I went home
and I was depressed and the reason I was
depressed is on stage that was me but
went home I was always mitigating
because I was too loud I was too this
that was to that and I had to make that
decision to say you know you failed
miserably in this area if someone else
may be happy but if you're not happy you
know what is this all for
thank you guys so much for watching my
goal with this series is to hang around
successful people and have some of their
pixie magic dust rub off on you so
hopefully you learned a little bit from
Tony today and I'd love to know which of
the clips was the most inspiring most
impactful what change you're gonna make
as a result of watching this leave it in
the comments below I will join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching and continue to believe and
I'll see you soon
somebody with vision and caring and
who's willing to work their tail off to
learn can take small risks and become
incredibly successful my assumption was
somebody like me oh sure Richard Branson
you'd assume you know you see him out
there taking these life risks he risked
his life but he doesn't risk in business
I mean if you look at Richard I believe
when he was opening up virgin the Virgin
air big risk to buy these giant
airplanes but his question always is
what's the worst-case now they were
protected and so you know he made a deal
what I believe was Boeing offender
correctly to see he could give back
those planes if over X amount a period
of time it didn't work out he's covering
his downside the average American isn't
doing that so I think it was it blew my
mind to see that these people are risk
takers but it's very calculated risk
it's small risks with big rewards that's
what set them apart so what I'm saying
is I just deal with myself called
priming every day I say look you've got
to have ten minutes for yourself you
don't ten minutes for yourself you don't
have a life and I'm not gonna hope I
feel good I just got back six countries
in 12 days that was an India two days
ago Wow I woke up here like feeling like
somebody ran me over with a truck do
this process ten minutes it put some
music on I do this massive change in my
breathing so it radically changes the
way I feel and then I do this three-step
process first I do three minutes of
gratitude or I think of three things I'm
really grateful for and I associate I
don't think of it I'm that I feel it and
the reason is when you're grateful you
can't be worried it can't be fearful
when you're grateful you can't be angry
and anger and fear what screw people up
most in their relationships and their
life in their business so I wire myself
I'm saying to you that most people want
to be happy but their habit is to be
worried or pissed off or frustrated or
stress and so they're they've got a high
way to stress and they got a dirt road
to happiness
so I wire myself I've got a highway to
gratitude which changes all your
emotions and then I do
three-minute process have kind of a
prayer for my family and friends and
then I do a three-minute process of the
top three things I want to accomplish I
see it as done I feel I'm done in 10
minutes so sometimes I go 20 but my deal
is 10 so there's no excuse not to do it
you know what I think it's a great way
to kind of set the tone for the day does
it change it changes listen we've all
had times when you snapped at somebody
and you felt bad because it wasn't them
it was the state you're in
right well there's no excuse of that if
you prime yourself you set yourself up
they've been studies where they go to
people and they have a man walk up to
you and say could you hold this for me
hand you a cup of coffee it's an actor
and they takes it six times pocket then
he takes it back and says thank you
hundred people they do it with iced
coffee how do people do with hot coffee
45 minutes later another actor comes by
and says listen we're doing this little
test for $5.00 would you read this three
paragraphs and answer three questions
most people say yes it's a little story
the questions are about the character
what's the character like 80% of people
that got iced coffee say the person is
cold and mean 81 percent of the people
that got hot coffee say the person is
warm and gentle or nice that's how much
we can be primed by our environment we
think we're just stealing what we're
feeling but our environment if we don't
take control of our environment it takes
control of us